-Thanks so much for coming back
on the show.
-So happy to be here.
Hey, guys, how you doing?
I just realized
I forgot to wear a shirt.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I just realized --
I just realized that I
remembered to wear a shirt.
[ Laughter ]
That's usually my look.
-Next time, we can trade off.
-Oh, how sad would that be.
Before we get into "Morbius,"
by the way,
I'm so psyched to talk to you
about that.
It is Nana Week here
at the show.
And I have a photo here of you
bringing your Grandma Ruby
to a premiere in 2004.
[ Audience aws ]
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Grandma Ruby.
-A little cheek pinch
right there.
-She got a hold, didn't let go.
-Yeah.
But you were telling me that
your Oscar-winning performance
in "Dallas Buyers Club,"
you took some of her mannerisms.
-You know what?
She had a heart of gold.
She was like the quintessential
Southern grandmother.
And when she wasn't chasing me
around with a fly swatter --
[ Laughter ]
-She did?
-Don't act like you've never
been schooled by your grandma.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's what grandmas do.
-I learned a lot of lessons.
-Of course,
that's what Grandma does.
-She wasn't afraid to teach me.
But actually, you know,
what's funny is
she was the first person --
I saw the original "Dracula"
because of her.
I was up late at night.
There was a giant cockroach
that ran across my neck.
That's another story.
[ Laughter ]
I was sleeping on the floor,
which you do when you're a kid.
-Of course.
-That's normal.
-I do it as an adult.
[ Laughter ]
Depends on what night it is.
-You never know what you're
gonna find down there.
But yeah, a cockroach, it was a
crazy thing. It was hysterical.
But anyway, I was up.
And she let me stay up and watch
the original "Dracula" with her.
And that's when I fell in love
with vampires.
Yeah. True story.
-Wow. No way.
-Yeah. Grandma Ruby!
-Grandma Ruby, shout-out to her,
yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to get into "Morbius,"
but first,
your show "WeCrashed" started
streaming earlier
this month on Apple TV+.
-Whoo!
-Everyone is talking about it.
You're trending every other day.
-I appreciate that one bit of
applause. That was very nice.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that one person.
Yeah. But it is.
People are talking about this.
-Yeah. It's a fun one.
-It's a real story.
-Yeah.
-You play a real guy,
Adam Neumann.
-Yeah, Adam Neumann who started
a little company called WeWork
and grew it from nothing into
a $47 billion empire.
Had a lot of success,
a lot of failure.
And we examined
this crazy story.
Really colorful character.
But it was a blast.
I do it with Annie Hathaway.
-Yeah, both of you guys
are fantastic.
-Thank you.
-Getting great reviews.
You get the accents down.
You know -- It's --
Is it an Israeli accent?
-It's an Israeli accent, yeah.
I had a great team of Israelis
helping me out and guiding me,
beating me up, coaching me.
-Telling you that's wrong.
-Making sure I never --
I didn't stray from the bath.
-Yes.
-But they were very --
They weren't delicate but they
were very -- they were amazing.
-Did you ever get to meet
the guy you were playing?
-You know, I did actually.
I had a top-secret meeting
with him.
And top-secret because it was
top-secret.
-Of course.
[ Laughter ]
Say no more.
-He spilled the beans recently,
so now I can talk about it.
But I met him.
I thought he was a lovely guy.
-And, well, I can tell you,
I watched "Morbius."
It's a giant Marvel movie,
and you're the first
to actually take him
from comic book to the screen.
Here is Morbius right here.
Charming-looking guy.
[ Laughter ]
He's neither good nor evil,
I would say.
-No, he's something in between.
-Yeah.
-That delicate dance
between good and evil.
But I like the complexity.
I definitely don't have
that nine-pack right there.
-They did throw an extra two
or three abs in there.
[ Laughter ]
But you do have -- your body
goes from frail into --
Basically, you feel bad for you
from the first scene.
I'm like rooting for you
since day one.
-Yeah. I start off playing
Dr. Michael Morbius,
who's this brilliant scientist
and doctor who's searching for
a very -- a cure
to a really rare disease.
He's sick and he's frail
and he's really dying
before our eyes.
So that was incredibly
challenging.
And then he becomes
strong and powerful
and then ultimately, monstrous.
-Well, your character invents
an artificial blood
which saves so many diseases
and actually gets award-winning
and you're a great guy
and that's awesome
that you did that, but then you
also have your own thing
that you're dealing with
and you go, "You know,
I want to research these
vampire bats in Costa Rica
and let's see what they're all
about 'cause they suck the blood
but maybe there's a way they can
take out the blood."
And you mix it with yours.
And there's a lot of centrifuge
in the movie --
any fans of centrifuge.
You get to see that in the film.
[ Laughter ]
-As soon as those vials start
spinning, oh, man, I'm in.
-That's when the movie
starts going.
And so, you're like,
"Maybe I can put --"
'Cause now you're
this famous doctor.
"I could put
a little vampire bat blood in me
and maybe save me and see what
happens." You test it.
-It's not the worst idea
I've ever heard.
-No, and you've tried
different things.
And you do it, and all of
a sudden, you're all-powerful.
-Yeah.
-And you can walk again.
-And you don't need crutches.
And you're like,
"Oh, wait, what's going on?"
Then you just start turning into
a vampire, a bat.
-Yes.
-Frightening.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Hisses ]
-Yes.
-Yes. Frightening.
-By the way,
that was pretty good.
-Thank you, I auditioned for it.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't get it.
I auditioned to play
your little brother.
I was like, yeah.
"If there's a sequel, you know,
you can give me a call."
-I would love to see him
in a sequel, would you not?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Here's your coffee,
Dr. Morbius."
-We could put a scene in there.
-"Here's your coffee,
Dr. Morbius."
-"Oh, thank you."
[ Laughter ]
-I would love to be --
But then you see what happens
in the movie,
and you start rooting for you
And you go, "We need Morbius."
-Yeah, we do.
-To stop the evil.
-We need Morbius to stop
the evil, that's for sure.
You know what? I have to say
this is the first time
that I've ever starred in
a very -- a huge film like this.
I've never -- My whole career,
I've made mostly
independent films
and made a career
out of playing smaller parts.
But this is, like, the first
time I've ever starred
in a big Marvel movie like this.
And I'm incredibly excited.
And it's the first time
that Morbius
has ever been on the screen.
So that was a big honor
to get asked
to bring this character to life.
-It's giant. Go see it in
the theaters. Go see it in IMAX.
Get popcorn. It's loud,
it's fun, it's exciting.
-Drink a little blood
if you want.
-Yeah, no, no, yeah,
the right type, of course.
I have to ask you about this.
You don't have to
answer or anything.
But you caused
a little bit of a stir,
which you tend to do,
but you were at the "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" premiere.
-Yes.
-And you go there,
and everyone is like, "Aw, cool,
Jared Leto is awesome.
He's a stud. We love this guy."
And then someone zoomed in, and
you were wearing this necklace.
It says just the number 6.
Now, there is a way -- there's
a thing called the Sinister Six.
I don't know if you heard.
Morbius, Spider-Man,
just saying, things happen.
This is here. You're here.
What just went down right now?
I showed that photo.
Your reaction is
very poker face, you know?
-It was actually meant
to be a 9.
It just got flipped.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
Oh, that's what it is.
Sorry about that.
Oh, now I get it.
There you go. It's alright.
There you go. I take it back.
Sorry. I apologize.
[ Laughter ]
There's no truth to that.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Jared Leto in "Morbius."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, it's fun.
Jared Leto, everybody!
"Morbius" hits theaters
this weekend.